the question presents to you this pair
of triangles it says they're similar
it's given us these angles here so we
know and you can see the shape the same
or characteristics to set up size and
then you have these legs here
this is what they want that's the ratio
of areas come back over here to what we
said before in this example if you
double the length double double the
areas so quadric okay well let's see
what happens if we follow this pattern
through on these guys in between the
first thing our way is the ratios of the
lengths now just rewind a little bit
this one or two you still got this on
your page maybe the previous page if you
turn the page when they get one to two
Franck where did that pair of numbers
come from it came from the sides one of
them was a seven and then 14 and then I
think the other one was 24 48 yeah good
now what I want you to notice is see
these guys to you right these are what
we call equivalent ratios in fact it
might be helpful to you if you serve
another color to actually write that
what these are called equivalent ratios
do you notice do you notice that these
equivalent ratios they behave a lot like
something else equivalent that you nerd
something we're dealt with this morning
which is fractions right equivalent
fractions behave in just the same way in
fact alongside here up choose another
color the fractures that would go with
this are 7 over 14 which is equal to 24
and 48 which is equal to a hundred well
the same fraction just dress up in
different clothes which by the way is
why fractions are often called rational
numbers it's not rational in that oh
yeah
he's rational he's saying he makes sense
he's sensible it means
fractions because they are ratios
rational is the adjective from which
ratios is the noun okay so this just
means numbers that are ratios okay so
therefore when I go to write these
ratios of legs what are the ratios of
legs in this question 7 14 2014 1 to 2
it's just this to this don't you agree
that this guy this guy just gonna write
them as these without changing them 1.5
to 2.5 okay but that's a bit awkward
just like we try to avoid writing
decimals and mixing them with fractions
we like to write things in whole numbers
so I'm going to just like I could with a
fraction I'm gonna multiply the top and
bottom by the same number so it ends up
a little bit simpler if I multiply both
of them by 2 then this would become
directly and this would become it's the
same ratio its equivalent but so much a
nicer way to write it do you agree okay
let's get those fractions anyway right
that's the ratios of the legs in order
to get to the ratios of the areas we
don't have to do to these guys
[Music]
have a look I have to swear right so I'm
gonna get ratios of areas but
importantly I'm gonna square both of
these numbers so they become three
squared - 5 squared right 3 squared of
course is 9 + 5 squared is 25 and that's
the ratio of the areas yeah yeah that's
the I got to do something that to get to
the okay so that's not too complicated
you can see what you've got to do is
carefully compare the lengths you've got
be careful these introductory questions
are trying to ease you in but sometimes
you get multiple different lengths so
look at this pair of triangles right
suppose I gave you another way what is
that one four meters something like that
okay if I'm trying to get these ratios
of legs I would not be able to ride one
point sorry one point five two four why
not yeah that's right so they're not in
the same position do you notice that we
have a special emphasis that's what see
when you shake twin size like this like
a congruence is when two shapes are are
exactly the same but these are exactly
the same item it's similar right but
what I'm looking for is and in fact you
can put it in for the word legs what I'm
looking for is corresponding sometimes
you might have seen them with matching
big cars my legs are slightly better
word to use but it's the same idea it's
not just aliens they've got to be the
ones that match up together the
correspond to each other so I'm okay for
you to just write ratios and plates but
it's an abbreviation of ratios of
corresponding weights just like when we
say hi we meet perpendicular height of
it we always mean that so we we leave
off the word perpendicular because we're
men all the time and it's long and we're
lazy to write it okay
cross one needs the same but you have to
pick the sides carefully not just any
sides it's the ones that correspond to
each
do you make sense you